[Applaudissements]
avant le tirage proprement dit vous êtes
affecté un des groupes et déjà le hasard
a voulu qu'on tire comme le club de
Ligue 2 labanger les deux premiers de
Ligue 2 donc bon après vous avez quand
même peu de chance qu'il y a 14 matchs
dans le group he et puis ça a pas loupé
c'est un gros j'avoue qu'il y a 5 ans
j'aurais voulu un gros on avit fallli
tomber PSG quand on est tombé car il
restait une boule c'était celle du
parisaingermain j'aurais voulu tomber
sur lance aussi que c'est V que lance
venait avec plusieurs milliers de
supporters là on avavait vraiment rien
anticipé on va jouer le jeu à fond et
croyez-moi que le staff et les joueurs
sont motivés mais en aucun cas on
pourrait leur mettre une pression de
gagner absolument on est réaliste en
gestanné c'est très solide ils ont
failli arriver comme leader ça s'est
joué quelques secondes près àô samedi
soir ils sont 2è ils ont un projet de
remonter en Ligue 1 ils ont le budget
pour les joueurs pour donc franchement
c'est un très gros morceau donc euh hors
de question de mettre une
pression qui serait pas appropriée aux
joueurs
staff alors les billets en tribune sont
à 15 € le portour 10 € et jeune 5 €
c'est ce qui se fait selon le calibre
l'adversaire il y a des clubs pour une
Ligue 2 qui vont à 20 € mais on s'est
dit quand même qu'il faut que ça reste
un événement accessible à tous bon donc
on a euh on a tenu compte là encore
notre expérience passée et les
différents matchs qu'
variété et cetera donc ça nous paraî des
tarifs abordables on a énormément de
demandeon on fait de la prévente pendant
3 jours et puis der Bill sont vendu le
jour
même